hey it turns out that vice president
Mike Pence used a personal email account
and AOL account no less and was also
hacked of course the back story Hillary
Clinton's emails FBI letters press
conferences arguably a big part of
Hillary Clinton losing the election at
least the baggage associated with the
email scandal of Hillary Clinton we've
now learned that none other than our
buddy vice president Mike Pence
routinely was using his private AOL
email account to conduct public business
when he was governor of Indiana also
shocking Mike Pence was using America
Online that that we should probably
devote an entire segment just to that I
can imagine him hoarding those CDs that
used to come in the mail saying hey 23
hours of AOL I'm guessing you don't know
that reference right Pat that's before
your time little before my time yeah
some of our audience will get that Mike
Pence communicated via his personal AOL
account with his top advisors on topics
ranging from security gates at the
governor's residence to how Indiana will
respond to terror attacks across the
globe there were sensitive matters
discussed there were issues of Homeland
Security discussed in one email pensa
stata top state Homeland Security
Advisor relayed an update from the FBI
regarding the arrest of several men for
federal terror related charges and cyber
security experts rightly so are saying
hey these this revelation raises
concerns about whether sensitive
information was being adequately
protected because Mike Pence's personal
account was actually hacked last summer
it's also an issue of disclosure and
transparency because as you probably
know from the allegations we heard from
the right about Hillary Clinton's emails
when you use personal email those emails
are not immediately captured on State
servers that could then be subject to
public records requests yes some of the
emails would be transferred over into
the state record but not all of them and
of course Mike Pence is being defended
by people saying hey David this wasn't
against the law neither was Hillary
Clinton's private email that's not
actually what was at issue here yeah and
right for the sake of consistency I
don't think it's a big deal that Mike
Pence use the private email server I
also didn't think it was a
big deal that Hillary Clinton and Colin
Powell use it as well I think it may
show bad judgment but I don't think
there should be any charges pressed
against them or even much political
repercussions but it's hypocrisy I mean
clearly this was the hallmark of their
campaign that she messed up by using a
private email server and Trump goes
ahead and picks a vice president who did
the exact same thing it's a total double
standard and people defending pence by
saying well the stuff he dealt with his
governor wasn't as sensitive as what
Hillary Clinton was dealing with the
Secretary of State vet shades of gray I
mean we know that some of the emails
related to be responses to terror
attacks homeland security issues that's
sensitive enough if the critique is that
it is absolute scandal to use private
email then you can't say well the stuff
that pence was dealing with was slightly
less sensitive less sensitive so it's
not a big deal it's it's stunning to me
that almost everything that the Trump
campaign attacked the Clinton campaign
for is something that at some point
either Trump or his associates were
guilty of having done themselves will we
ultimately see any significant political
repercussions for this probably not as
Pat is pointing out discuss this with us
on our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash r ed di t gamefly is
sort of like netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you would return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s